money really is the energy which fuels
your life people don't understand that
if you do not have access to your money
if you're not free to use your money as
you wish you really can't participate in
society whether it's choosing what car
you want to drive whether it's choosing
how much meat you want to eat all these
different things and when they control
the money they literally control you in
America for example they're trying to
ban the Second Amendment we don't really
need to ban the Second Amendment
necessarily in order to stop people
buying it you just control their money
and so they can't then go ahead and buy
a gun so if you control the money you
really control every aspect of a
person's life